Tại con tình từ tập đoàn để lực Việt Nam, AVN trước sĩnh biến phúc ta của lũ lũ trên địa bàn tình nghề An,
con tì địa lực nghề An, BC nghề An đã huy động tòa lực.
Hình trước trình khai các phương án kiểm tra, sử lý và khôi phục hệ thống định tại các khu vực bị án vừa,
với mục tiêu bảo đảm An tòa đảm và sớm cấp định trở lại trong người dân.
Tình đến sáng 2,5 năm tháng 7, con tì địa lực nghề An đã khôi phục mấy chăm 5,5 tổng số chiến 2,5 tín trạm biến áp bị án vừa.
Cứ định trở lại cho hơn ta mấy bàn nghĩ khách hàng,
gó phần dút người dân vùng lũ sớm ổn định cuộc sống và khôi phục sản xuất.
Chừng tiết có mặt tại hiện chương,
giám đốc công ty định lực nghề An đã chỉ đạo xa sau việc ước phó và khách cuộc sử của.
Các đội xung kích được vi động tòa ra, với hợp trở trẻ với chính quyền địa phương,
bám xát địa bàn, sử lý nhang các địa mặt lợi,
ngọt ủng, bảo đảm điều kiện An tòa mối tín hành đám biệt,
không chỉ tập trung vào khôi phục hả tăng biệt,
lực lượng cán mộ công nhân viên định lực con tích cự khối trở người dân sọng dễ.
Bệ sinh nhà cửa sau lũ, thế hiện tình thần chắc nghiệp,
sẽ chia vào đồng hành cùng bà con vượt qua khó khăn,
bởi phương trâm nước xuất đến đâu, đến khôi phục đến đó,
công ty định lực nghề An tích tục nỗ lực tương dầu để đưa dòng định trở lại với ninh dân trong thời gian sớm nhất,
đặc biệt tại các khu vực biệt của lợp, vùng sâu, vùng sà.